foreign
sisters helped to feed those who are in
poor conditions and who don't even have
a clothing to keep theirself warm your
small donation might mean nothing to you
but it can change their life and help
them survive the winter this year
brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes and we ask Allah to accept it from
him he the videos that you can see on my
left side on my right side is him
performing that nice even saw one where
he is actually crying he's like in in
theaters in front of the camera and when
it comes to this stuff usually we look
at the intentions the actions and also
what is the criteria that we use that a
umra a Hajj or the fasting Ramadan that
we do has been accepted many scholars
say a good sign is that after you do
this that you stop doing the sins that
you did previously now this is very can
be generic Etc or specific from
Individual to individual because at the
end of the day yes DJ Khalid went there
he did perform umrah but if I'm not
mistaken before after he went back to
doing a concert you know doing the music
in Riyadh actually sadly the point is
this number one we do not question a
person's intentions okay for the action
to be accepted intentions have to be
there and the action has to be according
to the Sunnah if the intentions is not
there whether action is there doing the
action of umrah by his intentions for
other reasons arguments say
it's not accepted if his intentions are
there and his actions which is he does
something which the Quran doesn't tell
him argument say he goes and goes around
the Kaaba the opposite direction of
course that's not going to be accepted
so we assume that we know the actions
were correct and we assume that his
intentions were in the right place and
the fact that he looked emotional
subhanallah that we ask Allah accept it
from him and the reward of umrah is what
the prophet sallam said that's from
umrah to umrah all the sins in between
that is expirated obviously the scholars
they found this is it major minor you
know mostly if I'm mistaken the correct
opinion is that it's minor sense major
since you have to repent specifically
for yes and the process even talked
about you know gender so the rewards are
immense we have these rewards from uh um
it's his immense and if he knew the
reward of the umrah he would be dancing
I don't know he's dancing like this yeah
he's doing some dance with the sword
Martin yeah uh but I hope he's dancing
like this because he understands the
rewards of umrah yeah he understands was
I think that's the reason I want to give
him good assumptions I'm thinking he's
dancing like this not for the Saudi
government he's doing this for the umla
that he performed subhanallah and may
Allah keep us guided inshallah and
protected